Hello everyone, this is Steve Gilbert.
Welcome to week 5 and lecture 17.
So today we're going to be talking about memory and pointers.
In the next lecture we're going to be working with graphics.
So before we do that though, let's do a little bit of review on vectors.
So we create vectors by specifying the kind of thing
that they're going to hold, called the base type.
So v1 is a vector of int, v2 is a vector of int, all of these are vector of int.
When we can create them, we can pass additional arguments to their constructor.
And so if we pass a single integer, it says I want v2 to be an array of 10 integers,
or a vector of 10 integers, zero initialized.
If I don't want them zero initialized, I can pass two integers.
So v3 is an array of three integers, all three are initialized to four.
Or if I don't use the parentheses after the constructor,
when I'm constructing the object, if I use braces instead,
I'm saying that I want simply the values three and four.
I'm list initializing them.
We saw that we could access the individual elements in a vector with at,
or front and back to get the first and the last one,
or the square brackets, or the square brackets.
We have members that change the object.
We can get pushback and popback.
Those both mutate the object.
Pushback adds an item to the end of the list,
and popback removes that item that's at the end of the list.
Of course, if you call popback on an empty vector, you'll have an error.
Size is an accessor.
It tells us how many elements the array has.
And we looked at several different loops in our exercises in the last lecture.
We used the range-based loop.
We can use the range-based loop with references, and so forth.
So to just make this a little bit less theoretical,
let's go ahead and do some vector function practice.
So you pass passing vectors as function parameters.
You always use a const vector ref, or a vector ref for an input or output parameter.
We will never, ever pass a vector by value.
We can also return a vector from a function.
You simply create an empty vector.
We did this with the next to the last version of unique in the last lecture.
Fill it in, and then return it.
Now, that makes a copy.
And so adding an output parameter-- in other words,
passing in an empty vector by reference-- may be more efficient.
But actually, modern compilers will actually optimize that copy away.
Since C++ 11, they're required to do that.
Now, imagine that you are writing a program that is going to a web
application, say, and you're writing the guts of it in C++.
And you need to process the-- on the phone, on a phone--
you need to process the camera roll.
And all your application does is it looks through a person's camera roll,
and it shows them a view of the pictures that have a cute cat in it.
Now, you might think that you would pass in the camera roll as a vector of images.
But remember, each image is quite large, so we don't want to make a copy.
But because we're using input parameters, a const vector ref, we won't make a copy.
It'll be very, very inefficient.
We won't make duplicates of all those millions and millions of bytes.
However, if you want to show them your pictures that have cats in it--
the pictures of the cute cat pictures-- you
may be tempted to create an empty vector of pictures,
fill it in with just the cat pictures, and then return it.
And that would be very, very inefficient,
because we would make duplicates of all those millions of bytes
of each cat picture, when really all we need to do
is return a vector of the indexes into the camera roll.
And then all your application would do is have to look at that.
So that's very, very common to return a vector of indexes
that's then used to index into the original vector.
So for our first exercise here, we're going to complete these three functions.
So again, make sure you've gone to week five, the second tab for Tuesday,
on enumerations and memory.
Gone to the lecture exercise and click the link for the starter form.
When you have the starter form here, we're going to do these exercises right there.
These exercises right there.
So let's go over.
Let's look at IC17.
Let's look in vectors.h.
These are the files we're going to create.
And let's look at vectors.cpp.
Now, if you don't modify these and you just click a couple of them,
it doesn't reopen it, which is kind of frustrating.
So I'm going to open vectors.cpp and put my name on it.
Now I'm going to open vectors.h, and it'll open a new tab at the top,
which is what I want.
So here are the functions we want.
We want to write swap ins, match up, and copy evens.
So I'm going to copy all of those.
So I don't simply have to go back and forth between them.
And then as we do it, I'll remove the comments.
So let's take our things here and just stub them out so that our code will always compile.
So that's void.
This function returns an int.
And so I'm going to just return 0 here.
Again, just to get a skeleton that works, copy evens.
OK, so this is returning a vector.
So I'm going to create a vector int the result.
And I'm going to return the result.
OK, let's get a shell here.
And I can close that.
And let's just do make test to make sure that our code compiles
and we don't have any syntax errors on it.
We don't, OK?
So now we can go back to thinking about the code.
So this first function we're going to write is going to have one parameter,
which is an input/output parameter, a vector of int named nums.
And if the vector length is greater than 0, then we're going to swap the first and last element.
Now actually, it should be if the vector length is greater than 1,
because if the vector length is 1, swapping the first and last elements gives me the same result.
So I want to say if nums size is greater than 1, I'm going to swap them.
Now to swap them, I have to temporarily save one value.
And so I'm saving the first and the last.
So I could do it four or five different ways.
So first, I'm going to say int temp equals nums sub 0 or nums front,
because it's a vector, or nums at 0.
Now, so we can use all three of those, nums sub 0, nums.front, nums at.
I like using nums.front, because it's kind of, you know, it's expressive.
So I'm going to say, so I saved the first one.
So now I'm going to change the first one, nums.front equals nums.back.
And again, for nums.back, we could have written nums at nums size minus 1.
Certainly nums.back is easier than doing that, right?
And again, we could have used the square brackets with the same expression.
And finally, I'm going to say nums.back equals temp.
So this algorithm is called the swap algorithm.
And in fact, it's in the standard library.
So you generally don't need to write it yourself.
You can just call the one in the standard library, and it will work fine.
Okay, let's try it.
Let's open our shell.
Let's do make test.
And all of our swap ins here should work fine.
For the second function we're going to write,
we're given a vector int nums1 and nums2 of the same length.
And for every element in nums1, consider the corresponding element nums2 at the same index.
So nums1 sub 0, nums2 sub 0.
Return the count of the number of times that the two elements differ by 2 or less, but are not equal.
So a couple different conditions.
So we're returning a count, so I'm just going to call that variable.
It matches 0, and I'm going to return the matches.
Now I'm going to visit each element in both vectors.
So could we use a range-based loop? No.
We need to use a standard while or for loop. I'll use while.
And because it told us they're the same length, I don't need to worry about that.
That would be a slightly different problem.
So I'm going to say for size t, i equals 0,
len equals nums1.size. Again, it doesn't matter which one I use because they're the same size.
i less than len, plus plus i.
OK, so now if nums1 at i is not equal to nums2 at i,
and again, for nums2 I'll do it like that, just so you can see that you can use either one of those.
I try and train my fingers to do at.
So if those are not equal, and the two elements differ by two or less,
so how do we find out if something differs from each other?
We subtract it.
So nums1 at i minus nums2 at i is two or less, less than or equal to two.
Then we're going to say matches plus plus.
Now if you test this, you'll see a slight problem. Let's test it and see what that problem is.
Oh, actually we didn't see it. Oh yeah, two of them didn't pass.
So the problem is that when we take this, this only works if nums1 is larger than nums2.
In the case where that's not the case, in cases where that is not the case,
so in this case num1 is larger than num2, and I'm subtracting in this case.
So it's not working in that case.
So I need to think slightly different about that.
This gives me the difference, but the difference can be positive or negative.
So what do I really want to do?
I want the absolute value of that difference.
So I'm going to use the function from cmath,
or actually this version of abs is from cstandard lib.
So I have to include cmath in here.
So it's from cstandard lib that knows how to use integers.
I didn't include cstandard lib, so I probably should include.
So include cstandard lib using standard abs.
Okay, so let's try our code again for that function.
Okay, and now all of the matchups work 100%.
Okay, for the last test we're going to be doing here,
we're going to be doing -- so I'm going to get rid of my code for this.
The last review exercise we're doing is one where we're returning a vector.
So we're getting a vector of positive ints.
We're going to return a new vector array of length count,
containing the first even numbers from the original vector.
The original vector will contain at least count even numbers,
but it may contain more.
So we have two input vectors, or two input values.
Nums is a vector of int, so it's const vector ref.
And ecount is the number of even numbers in the return vector.
Now you might wonder why I didn't do ecount like that.
Now you could do that, but then you'd have to keep track of where you are in the two vectors.
And it's actually easier to do it like this.
While result size is less than ecount.
As soon as we have the correct number of items in result,
then our function is completely over.
We're done with what we need to do.
So what we want to do is we want to look through nums.
So I want to say for --
Oh no, actually I don't want to look through nums.
I want to say size pi equals zero.
If nums at i remainder two equals zero,
if nums at i is even, then add it to the result.
So add the number at i to the result.
Each time we go through the loop, of course, we need to do i++.
So we're looking at the correct element in nums.
So this is not a counter controlled loop.
This counter is being used to index into this.
So the loop is only going to stop when result size gets to ecount.
But our counter is actually being used to index into this while we go through that loop.
OK, so let's see if copy evens works.
And there copy evens works perfectly now.
Copy evens works perfectly.
OK, so a little review from the last lesson, last lecture.
Let's go and talk about new items today.
We're going to start looking at lower level.
We're going to start drilling down into your computer and how your computer actually works.
When you run a program, when you run an executable,
your program runs a little part at the beginning of it called the startup code.
That startup code is usually a function called start that is added by the linker.
What that does is it sets the machine registers and it allocates memory.
And so the memory it allocates is divided into sections.
And machine registers point to each of these.
So the static area, the part that's loaded directly from disk,
this is in memory a picture of the image that you have on disk.
This static area has code.
That's the section marked down here as text.
And it has all of your global variables.
They're loaded into memory from disk when the program ends.
And the machine registers, the code segment is set to point to this code.
The data segment is set to point to these global areas.
Those are registers on the machine.
At the opposite end from where the memory is loaded into code,
at a higher address up here, we have something called the stack.
And again, this is just memory reserved for local variables and run time information.
The return of disk, the mechanics of calling a function, parameters,
all of that are placed in this area of memory called the stack.
And as more items are added, the memory grows in this direction,
down towards the static section.
In between those is a third section.
This is called the free store or the heap.
And this is where dynamic variables are created.
When you ask the operating system for some new data,
for instance, when you're reading a file.
So, for instance, if you ask the user to input a sentence,
you don't know how long the sentence is.
And so we cannot put that data on the stack or in the static storage area.
It has to be determined depending on how much data they do.
And the string class does that for you automatically.
We'll work with the heap in a little bit.
But right now, just know that it's where dynamic memory, like strings and vectors, go.
So, with variables and functions as well, we have three related concepts.
The first concept is scope.
Where in your code can you see a name from?
So scope is visibility.
And C++ has two kinds of scope.
Something that is created inside a block.
For instance, a function body or the body of a for loop or an if statement.
Something that's created inside the block is only visible from the point it's created
to the end of the block that it was created in.
Now sometimes this will be called local scope, but it's really not local scope, it's block scope.
If you create something outside of a block, it has what's called file scope.
File scope means that that name is visible from the point it's created to the end of the file that it was created in.
Including inside any blocks.
So block scope and file scope.
Secondly, we have duration.
In other words, how long does an item stay in memory?
Now global variables, variables that are loaded into the static storage area,
they persist as long as your program runs.
You start running the program, the variable is created right at that moment.
You stop running the program, the variable goes away.
It stays at the same location.
So static in this sense means it doesn't move.
Now when you create a local variable, when does it come into existence?
When the code is executed, that creates it.
When does it go away?
When the function or the block that you created it in ends.
And so these variables are created on the stack up here, as I mentioned before,
and they have what we call automatic duration.
So they're automatic variables.
Finally, we have variables, I mentioned them just briefly before,
we're not going to create any now, that have dynamic duration.
In other words, in one part of your program you can say,
create this variable now, we do that with a new operator, like you do in Java,
and in another part of this program we can say,
I'm done with this, you can have it back to the operating system.
Finally, when we have multiple files working together,
those files are linked together.
So you compile two CPP files, you link them together,
which variables and which functions from which file can be used in which other file.
So linkage determines which files and which functions can be used in each other.
So if something has internal linkage,
if I create a variable in one file using file scope,
in other words, outside of a function,
that variable can have internal linkage,
meaning it can only be used inside that file,
or it can have external linkage,
meaning I can use it in that file and any other files that are linked in.
So internal or external linkage,
both of these have to do with functions and global variables.
All other variables, local variables, have no linkage.
They can only be used in the function that they're created in.
So let's go look at a program, F1 and F2.
I'm going to try and open them side by side.
This is the first time we've been using this IDE right here.
So this might be an interesting video.
So here's F1 and here's F2.
That's good.
That's F1 and F2.
Let me...
I've got F1 and F2.
I'm still trying to do it. There's F2.
That's pretty good, and I'll move this over there.
So here's F1 and F2.
Notice that there's only one main function in F1 and F2.
Actually, let me do one more thing.
I'm going to open up a terminal on that folder.
I'm simply going to type "nick run."
Main first calls the function C.
C is not defined in file F2, but it is linked together, and it's defined in file F1.
So function C is over here, and it prints out the variables A and B.
Now notice A is defined outside of any function here. It's a global variable.
B also is defined outside of every function, and it's a global variable.
So it prints out A and B, and so we get 37, and there's a new line.
Then it calls the function D.
So here's the function D.
It creates a local variable E, another local variable F, 5 and 6,
and it prints out A, B, E, and F.
So we get 37 like we did before, and 56 just like you'd expect.
Then we increment this variable F right here.
So now we set A to 12, B to 13, and we call C again.
So it's going to print A and B.
So notice that the variable A lives over here.
It's defined in F1, and we're changing it over here in F2.
It's declared here so we can use it, and the function C is declared there so we can use it.
But now when I print A and B, you would expect to get 12 and 13.
But it looks like this file has its own copy of B, and so instead I get 12 and 7.
So this A changes to 12, but this B doesn't change to 13.
It still says 7, so I get 127.
Then I call D again.
E is set to that.
It looks like F is set to 6.
I print A, B, E, and F, but instead of getting 12, 7, 5, 6, I get 12, 7, 5, 7.
So apparently this F++ kept this variable in the past.
So let me explain what is happening here.
Variables and functions have what we call external linkage and file scope.
So all these variables, all these functions are visible from here down to here.
File scope, external linkage, static duration.
Now, local variables like E has block scope.
It's visible only from here to the end of the function.
F has block scope visible from there to the end of the duration.
However, for these variables, this has automatic duration,
meaning it comes into existence on the stack and is destroyed when the function ends.
Because of this keyword static here, we're saying F is going to be stored in the static storage area,
not on the stack, which is why when I increment it after calling the function once,
the next time we come around, it's not reset to 6 here.
It has the value 7 down there.
It has the value 7.
That leaves only one thing left to explain,
and that is why is this word static in front of this variable and this function?
We saw what it meant here with this local variable.
It means it still cannot be used anywhere other than the function.
It has block scope.
Yeah, it has block scope.
It only can be seen here.
Even though it's stored the whole time your program is running, unlike E in this case.
The static in front of a function or a global variable means that it has internal linkage.
So this B will always and only be this B.
It will never be this B over here.
It will never be that B over here.
These are two separate B's that are only visible inside their own function,
or only exist inside their own function.
So when I set B equal to 13 here, I get this B, not this B.
When I set A equal to 12 here, I get this A.
Now, why can I use this A inside this function?
Because it's obviously not in scope.
I brought it into scope by declaring it.
So I declared A, I declared C, we now know the name, and I can use A and C in that function.
So we had some exercises we're going to do with this and some questions.
So I want to see what will happen in line 1 if I remove the word extern from this.
What if I just change that to int A?
Do I get an error now when I try and do make run?
So make run.
Yes, I get an error.
So now, when the linker comes along, it sees two copies of A.
Both of them could be used in either file, but you can't have two things that have the same name.
So I have multiple definitions of A.
It's a linker error.
So I'm going to come over here and I'm just going to put my answer here.
Oops. Save the wrong thing.
Copy that.
Again, that copy didn't work, did it?
From the thing.
So I'm going to do that.
Right click.
Can't seem to get a copy of the terminal.
So I'm just going to type in multiple definitions of A.
It's only one definition of each object in an executable.
That's called the one definition rule or the ODR, the one definition rule.
I still want to see if I can copy that.
Doesn't look like it.
Weird.
Okay, so we're going to put extern back to that.
Okay, let's look at the second one here.
Now we're going to remove the word static from the definition of B on F1.
Does the program still compile and link?
Does the program run differently?
Does the change to B on F2.cpp line 9 have any effect since B now has external linkage in file 1?
So I'm going to remove the static from B on line 5 in F1.
And I'm going to do make run.
Now, 3756, 12757 runs exactly the same.
So the answer is no difference.
Runs the same.
Can you remove the static from both definitions of B?
Let's remove it over here.
Let's do make run.
Oops, no, multiple definitions of B.
Okay, I've discovered how to copy.
It looks like you just select the text, right click.
Apparently it's copied here.
And I can go error, multiple definitions of B.
We're breaking the ODR rule.
So again, we can't have two variables B with external linkage just like we can't have two A's.
So let's turn them back to internal linkage.
Right where we left off.
Okay, now in F1 we have a declaration for C.
Let's add a call to the declaration for D.
So just like I have the function C here, I have a declaration for C here and I can call C here.
Can I do the same thing for D?
So can I write void D and then call the function D from here?
Let's see.
So make run.
No, we have an undefined reference to D.
That's because in a function if you have static in front of it, it means give this function internal linkage.
The function D can only be called from F1.
It cannot be called from FT.
So let's copy our error message there.
So function has internal linkage and only be used in file F1.cpp.
Okay, so let's remove that.
So that didn't work.
Now, can we add an extern declaration?
So notice that I could use the variable A over here by adding an extern over there.
Can I use an extern to allow me to use the variables E and F?
So let's do extern int E, extern int F.
Let's do E equals 4, F equals 12.
And let's compile that and try it.
So make run.
Now we've got two things here.
Notice I have an undefined.
Copy both those.
And here's what happens.
Both variables are locals so they have no linkage.
Can't be used outside of function D.
So that's the explanation for what happens there.
Okay, so that doesn't work.
Let's see what other questions we had.
If I remove the static from the definition of the local variable F, what happens?
So first let's make run.
So 37, 37, 56, 127, 127, 57.
I'm going to remove static.
I'm going to do make run.
Notice now that the variable F doesn't retain this F++.
Now this variable has automatic duration.
It's stored on the stack.
Before it was stored in the static storage area and it didn't move.
So each time we come into this function we get a new copy of F here.
Before we did not.
So notice the 57 and the 56.
This is where it's stored in the static storage area.
This is where it's stored on the stack.
So we can say F no longer retains its value between function calls
because it now has automatic storage instead of static storage.
Okay, so we looked at linkage.
We looked at changing duration.
Put that back the way it was before.
Now let's just change the order of these two functions here in F1.
I'm just going to grab C.
And I'm going to move it up above D here.
And I'm going to do make run.
And this is the first time I've got a red error here.
Red error says D was not declared in this scope.
D was not declared in this scope.
So I see D right here.
Why isn't it declared in this scope?
Well, remember this has to do with scope.
So this is a scope problem.
So notice that C has file scope.
It's visible from there to there.
It's visible from its point of declaration to the end of the file.
D also has file scope.
It's visible from its point of declaration to there.
But I'm trying to use D up here.
So I'm using D before it's defined or declared.
So it is out of scope.
So using D before defined or declared.
And let me, it says show me, so let me.
And I'm just right clicking.
Even though there's no symbol that anything happened.
And I'm pasting in what I just real clicked there.
All right, so a little bit of exploration with memory.
So let's go explore a little bit more about variables, sizes, and addresses.
So all variables have three addresses.
So if I want to put something in a variable, I use its name.
I don't say put something in that storage location that's at address 3000.
I don't use its memory address.
I use its name.
All variables have a type that determines what I can store in the variable.
I can't store an integer in a string.
I can't store a string in an integer variable.
It also determines what valid operations can happen to that data.
And finally, inside that storage location, we have some data or some state or some value.
We call that the value.
Now, when you have a variable, you can also, instead of using the name, find out exactly where it is located.
And so that operator is called the address of operator.
It's the ampersand, and it's used in front of a variable instead of after a type.
So after a type, we're saying int ref n.
n is a reference to an integer.
Before a variable, cout ampersand n says give me the address of n.
So the address of operator returns the location of the object.
And the size of operator returns its storage size in bytes.
So we can see more technical details about how data is actually stored in memory, not just the logical details.
So let's do that in our next exercise.
Let's print the address and size of each variable by saying n lives at-- this is the address-- and uses xx bytes.
So let me close F1 and F2.
Let me close that terminal, throw it away.
Let's come down here to C and open up variables.cpp.
I actually need to open a terminal so we can run it.
Let me right-click on C, open a terminal.
OK, so here I've created a variable with file scope, static storage duration.
It's a constant, pi.
It's a global.
And here I have created a variable n, an int, a string, and an employee object.
So a structured variable.
And here I've printed out the various names.
Now obviously I have to have an overloaded operator for me to be able to print out the waiter, but I do.
So now what we want to do is we want to print out the address and size of each one using this.
So I'm going to say cl n lives at-- and to get where n lives, I'm going to take the address of n.
And to get the number of bytes that n uses, I'm going to use size of n.
OK, so there's n.
Let's look at some of the other variables.
I'll just copy that.
So how about pi?
So I take the address of pi.
See how many bytes that uses.
Let's take name.
So I take the address of name and the size of name.
And finally, how about the waiter?
So I take the address of that variable waiter, where it lives, and the amount of space it uses.
OK, let's run it.
Do make run.
So here's the name of this variable.
Here's the value it stores.
Here is where it lives.
Now this is a hexadecimal address.
And since it's an int, it uses four bytes.
Pi lives at an entirely different address.
Now you notice that this address is much smaller than this address.
It's 0x5, meaning it's closer to zero.
It's at the bottom of memory.
This is at the top of memory.
This is on the stack, as is this, as is this.
And these are next to each other in the stack if we looked at these values in something other than hexadecimal.
Pointers are always printed in hexadecimal or base 16 numbers.
So my integer uses four bytes.
My double uses eight bytes.
My name uses 32 bytes.
Now this will vary from compiler to compiler.
We're on GCC, on a Unix operating system, and we use 32 byte strings.
And waiter, which is a structure, uses 40 bytes for the parts that are inside the waiter.
Now, let's talk about pointers.
So we've seen how we can print out the address of a variable.
Could we store that in another variable?
Yes. These variables are called pointers.
So pointers don't hold integers or hold doubles.
They hold addresses of other variables.
So that's how they got their name, because since the address is another variable,
we say that variable points to another variable.
We create a pointer like this.
The kind of thing we're pointing to, the point E, a star, and the name of the pointer.
So here's an example with int pointer.
So iPointer is a pointer to an integer.
You read this from the right to the left.
You find the name. iPointer is a pointer to an integer.
Now, you might wonder about the space before or after the star. It doesn't matter.
I could write int star and put the star next to the int, put the star next to the iPointer.
It's entirely irrelevant.
However, you need to make sure that every pointer variable has its own star.
So if I were to write this, int star iPointer, comma, i, i is not a pointer.
i is an int.
So iPointer is a pointer to an int. i is an int, not a pointer to an int.
Now, unless you initialize a pointer, it just points to a random address in memory.
It's uninitialized.
And that is very, very, very bad.
So you can initialize a pointer using no pointer, that keyword,
or you can put in just zero.
That signifies that the pointer is unused.
Now, you might wonder, could I initialize a pointer with this address, that number, like that?
And the answer is no, you cannot.
In early versions of C, you could, but now you cannot.
No other literal integer value is permitted.
Now, you can return, you can call the address of operator,
which is what we just used to print out the addresses,
so that address operator returns an address,
and we can use that to initialize a pointer.
We could use the new operator,
which we're going to look at in our section on dynamic memory,
and initialize a pointer with the new operator, memory on the heap,
or we could use a function that uses one of these techniques,
or one of the C functions, that sort of thing.
So let's complete part two of variables.cpp,
and add some pointers inside there.
Now, there's nothing to print for this part,
but what I'm going to do is I'm going to create some pointers,
and you can create the pointer like this,
so int pointer ip, int pointer, equals the address of n.
We could do it like this, const double pointer dp
equals the address of pi.
Could we just say double pointer dp equals the address of pi?
Let's see what happens if we did make on that.
Now, it says that's an error,
because this, the address, pi, is a constant double,
and taking the address of a constant double
doesn't lead a double pointer, it leads a const double pointer.
Now, could we do this?
We could do that, right?
So this is going to be initialized with whatever this returns,
and so we could just use auto for that as well.
So let's do a string pointer sp equals the address of name,
and an employee pointer ep equals the address of my waiter.
So you notice I can put the star in front of the variable.
I can use auto and skip the star altogether.
I can put it in front of the type.
It doesn't make any difference to the syntax there.
Okay, so a pointer is a variable.
That means it has a name, a type, and a value.
The value inside the pointer, we call its explicit value.
That's, in other words, what's inside the memory.
That's the address it contains.
But a pointer has a second value called its indirect value.
That's the value of the variable that it points to.
We retrieve that by using the indirection or dereferencing operator, the star,
just like we did with iterators in vectors.
So here I have an integer, 3.
I've got a box in memory.
I put 3 inside the box.
I create a second box in memory, pa,
and inside pa, I put the address of this first box.
Now, to print out what's in the box,
print out the 3, I can print out the name of the variable,
or I can dereference the pointer.
Dereference a pointer says,
go to the address that the pointer contains
and give me back the value that's at that location.
Now, notice the star I've used twice in these two lines.
I've used it on line 1 where I'm declaring the pointer, int star pa.
This star here means pa is a pointer to int.
It's called the pointer declarator operator.
This star doesn't have int star in front of it.
It's just star pa.
This is a unary operator, and it's the dereferencing operator.
Now, the star means something different when declaring the pointer
or when dereferencing it.
Sometimes students get confused with that.
Now, the pointer also has an address which could be stored.
So I could say int star star or int star star star.
So int star star star pa is a pointer to a pointer to a pointer to an int.
So let's complete part 3, and we're going to print out
IP contains, what its explicit value is,
is stored at, its address, and the value that it points to.
Okay, so let's print the cout,
and I'm just going to put quotes around the xxx's
where we're going to replace it.
And let's do several of those.
So there's IP, DP, SP, and EP.
So this is DP, SP, and EP.
And for this part, we're going to say IP.
Right?
That's what it contains.
Like any variable, you use its name to get what it contains.
And DP, and SP, and EP.
Okay, to get what value it has,
now I'm going to try and use a trick here in Visual Studio.
I'm going to click there.
I'm going to hold down my alt key and click there.
No, that didn't seem to work.
I'm going to click there.
I'm going to hold down my alt key while I drag through.
Let's see if that works.
I'm going to try and copy that.
And I'm going to go here.
No, it didn't work.
I'm not quite sure on this editor how to get multi-line cursors.
Oh, you know how I think I can do?
I think I can hold down my alt key and the shift key.
No, didn't work.
I'm messing up.
I shouldn't be experimenting while I'm talking.
Let's just go ahead and do this manually.
So this is going to be the address of IP.
This is going to be the address of DP.
And this is going to be the address of SP.
And this is going to be the address of EP.
Now let's bring this one down here like that.
And that.
It's going to be easier to see.
So the last one is what it points to.
And it points to star IP.
And star DP.
Star SP.
And star EP.
So star EP dereferences this variable.
This gives me the value in the variable.
This gives me the location of the variable.
This dereferences gives me its indirect value.
Okay, let's open a terminal on that.
And then let's do make run.
And we can see the output of it.
So when we did IP, we pointed it to N.
So N lives at this address.
Now if we look inside IP, that's the address we find.
Notice that IP itself is stored at a completely different address.
But when we dereference IP, we get the same value that N had inside it here.
N had inside it.
Alright, so those are pointer basics.
Now a pointer input parameter should be const.
So if I have a function, I'm passing a pointer to it.
And I don't want to change what that pointer points to.
The pointer should be const.
If you don't put the const there, it will act like a reference.
So if I write int F and I pass int P, int star P.
That means that this pointer can change what P is pointing to.
It can change what P is pointing to.
So we're going to do that.
So this is just an example to show how we can use pointers instead of references for output parameters.
So we're going to write a function that takes a pointer to int.
We're going to fill the pointer's indirect value with a random number.
We're going to call one of the library functions called rand that's in the C standard library.
In main, we're going to create an int variable that's uninitialized.
We're going to pass its address to the function.
So when we call the function, we won't pass the variable name.
We'll use the address of the operator to pass it.
And then we're going to print the value both before and calling the function.
So let's close that terminal.
Let's close variables.cpp.
Go down to D.
So write a function that takes a pointer to int as its only parameter inside the function.
Fill the pointer's indirect value with a random number.
So it's not returning anything.
We'll call it randomize.
It's going to take a pointer to an int, an int pointer p.
Now if I assigned to p, I would change the value in the pointer.
I would point it somewhere else.
I don't want to do that.
I want to assign to what p points to.
Star p equals, and I'm just going to call the rand function from c standard lib.
That will just give me a random number.
Now you might wonder about this first line on line 21 here.
What this does is this gets the time on your hardware clock
and what we call seeds the random number generator.
So each time we run this function we'll get a different value.
If you took this off, you would get the same value each time.
It would be statistically random, but it would be exactly the same value each time you called the function.
Okay, so let's create an int variable.
I'm going to initialize it.
It says uninitialize.
I'm going to print the value of my variable.
See how before n is n.
I'm going to do that afterwards as well.
I'm going to change that before to after.
Now I'm going to call the function.
I can't simply say randomize n because the function doesn't want an integer.
It wants a pointer to integer.
So to call it with a pointer to integer, I can generate one by taking the address of n.
So this is an output parameter as a pointer.
So let's try that.
Let's get a shell here.
Let me do make run.
So notice before it had the value I put in it, 42.
After calling the function randomize with its address, the function took that address, changed the value inside n,
and when I print out n, it's an entirely different number.
Now as I said, the code here seeds the random number generator,
so every time you run this, you should get a different value.
Let me try it once again.
Yes, notice I'm getting an entirely different value for the random number here this second time.
So that's a pointer as an output parameter.
Alright, that's all we're going to do today.
And when you come back, we're going to look at using pointers like this and output parameters to modify images.
Thank you.